schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
es fällt schwer aktuell mitzukommen bei
dem hin und her den bedrohungen und
drohungen an der grenze zwischen
russland und der ukraine im osten des
landes in der region donners droht die
lage schon seit mehreren tagen zu
eskalieren immer wieder gibt es durch
gibt es dort meldungen dass es dort also
zu unruhen zu gefechten kommen soll dort
gilt eigentlich eine waffenruhe das
sogenannte minsker abkommen sollte das
garantieren aber das soll also immer
wieder gebrochen worden seien in den
letzten tagen und heute dann die meldung
der russische präsident putin so heißt
es sieht keine chance mehr für eine
umsetzung des minsker abkommens so hieß
es heute und außerdem das war eine
weitere meldung die heute kam will er
noch heute darüber entscheiden ob die
beiden ukrainischen provinzen lohans
unter jens als unabhängig anerkannt
werden sollen und das macht natürlich
die sorge vor einem russischen einmarsch
dort in der region noch größer das ist
heute also bei uns thema darum soll es
gehen eure fragen kommentare dazu sind
jederzeit hier bei uns im stream
willkommen denn wir wollen mit euch das
ganze versuchen ein bisschen besser
einzuordnen und zu beginn dieser sendung
wollen wir einsteigen mit einem beitrag
und auch mit einem gespräch das ich mit
dem journalisten ginzel kurz vor dieser
sendung führen konnte denn und ginzel
der ist zurzeit in der ost ukraine und
ist dort während eines interviews
während einer reportage selbst unter
beschuss geraten und in diesem beitrag
wollen wir jetzt zunächst mal
reinschauen
sonntag zwanzigster februar 25 kilometer
östlich von mario pohl unterwegs an der
sogenannten kontakt linie ich will
wissen wie es um frieden und waffenruhe
steht die hier im don was eigentlich
gelten sollen ich begleite siegfried
funkt er hier 2014 gemeinsam mit der
ukrainischen armee gegen die von
russland unterstützten separatisten
gekämpft hat ich habe dieses dorf mit
verteidigt und mit diesem dorf habe ich
auch mehr oder weniger übrig verteidigt
und ich war in diesem dorf stationiert
und
und manche ziemlich aufgenommen das dorf
seit jahren verlassen die bewohner
geflohen wir finden die stellung der
siegfried funk gekämpft hat oder eine
granate ist genau hier eingeschlagen so
unsere chancen dann
genau dort es ist 13 uhr ortszeit funkt
erklärt gerade wie wichtig präzise
karten sind die karten werden von der
einhalte hier angesetzt
aufstehen ist auch sitzen wurde neuer
kleinen dorf weit von einem kontakt
linie und wir werden jetzt hier gerade
mit panzer abgeschossen
geschossen müssen sind jetzt einen
kleinen ein kleines haus gegangen um in
sicherheit zu gehen
mehrfach schlagen granaten ein sie
kommen aus richtung der von russland
unterstützten separatisten
später reagiert die ukrainische seite
wir nutzen das gegenfeuer um den ort zu
verlassen
fest steht die spirale der gewalt dreht
sich immer schneller unter den bars und
die ukraine stehen näher an einem neuen
krieg als je zuvor
ich konnte vor dieser sendung mit arndt
ginzel sprechen dann bei 1 sicherheit in
einem hotel in mariupol und meine erste
frage war und dass eine einmalige aktion
war oder ob das inzwischen alltag ist
und öfter passiert je näher man sich
eben der grenze dieser kontakt linie
nähert
also wir sind ja seiten einigen tagen
schon hier in der region unterwegs und
wir hören immer wieder gerade wenn sie
an der sogenannten kontakt linie entlang
reisen fahren menschen treffen es ist im
prinzip dieser dieser sound des krieges
den haben sie permanent also sie haben
im hintergrund granaten sie haben
handfeuerwaffen das hören sie permanent
so das ist eigentlich nie präsentes
geräusch das kennen alle journalisten
die hier unterwegs sind und man merkt es
ist heftiger geworden und häufiger wir
können jetzt auch gerade neben ihnen im
bild können wir sehen wo sie sich da
genau aufhalten mario pohl und sie haben
uns kurz beschrieben dass man das jetzt
auch immer häufiger hört ist es denn
auch so dass sie jetzt immer mehr
ukrainisches militär dort sehen auf der
seite wo sie sind oder beschreiben sie
beschreiben sie uns so ein bisschen wie
sich das dort geradeaus an der grenze
naja wir sehen wir sehen natürlich
ukrainisches militär wir haben viele
checkpoints es gibt ja viele viele
kontrollen an den straßen an den
ausfahrten der orte und dörfer
militär ist omnipräsent
jedem fall aber
wenn sie eine wenn sie in so einen ort
rein kommen wie wir eben am gestrigen
vormittag da war da nicht mehr viel da
sind dann zwei drei soldaten die uns
noch über den weg gelaufen sind das ist
ein kleiner ort
das verteilt sich auf diese region und
auf diese lange lange konfliktlinie
und jetzt ist es eine ziemlich fest
zumindest hier so weit weg von außen von
uns betrachtet nämlich unübersichtliche
lage zum teil und es gibt scheint ja
auch zwei lager zu geben und das heißt
also immer wieder die ukraine die betont
sie würden eben keine offensive gegen
die prorussischen separatisten planen
vorhaben oder ausführen aber die
prorussischen separatistenführer die
sprechen immer wieder davon dass sie
also massiv unter beschuss sein wie ist
das einzuordnen diese zahl
widersprüchlichen aussagen
ja es ist natürlich für uns absolut
schwierig weil wir haben immer nur einen
kleinen ausschnitt den wir überblicken
können aber es gibt natürlich auch die
osze und die osze-beobachter und die
einzelne verstöße gegen die waffenruhe
quasi versuchen zu registrieren und
nachzuweisen haben jetzt das vorher wer
hat gegen was verstoßen unser also mein
eindruck ist im augenblick die ukraine
versucht eigentlich sich eher
zurückzuhalten
dass sie keinen vorwand für eine größere
russische intervention
auch das was wir gestern erlebt haben
das feuer ging aus unserer sicht und aus
unserer wahrnehmung ganz klar von der
von der gruppen den pro-russischen
rebellen aus die haben angefangen zu
feuern und im endeffekt haben dann die
ukrainischen soldaten quasi geantwortet
auf dieses feuer sie mussten sich ja
selbst auch in sicherheit bringen was
gibt's da wird für möglichkeiten für die
menschen vor ort sich dort in sicherheit
bringen zu können
ja hier in mario pohl in der großstadt
haben wir gesehen da gibt es halt
luftschutzbunker in den großen
mietshäusern in den dörfern und in den
ländlichen regionen ist es dann schon
schwieriger
sich da zu schützen viele menschen sind
weggegangen bin schon wie den jahren
davor weil das jetzt eine situation ist
die schon einige jahre anhält nur eben
jetzt wieder mit einer etwas stärkeren
intensität also es wird mehr geschossen
als vielleicht noch vor einem jahr die
haben wenig chancen sich wirklich in
sicherheit zu bringen in diesen
ortschaften das ist so jetzt haben sie
den fall beschrieben also in diesem
moment wo sie da also unter beschuss
waren dagegen das wohl von den pro
russischen separatisten aus jetzt gibt
es ja international auch immer wieder
die sorge dass vielleicht russland das
also als vorwand nehmen könnte dass es
quasi eine behauptung gibt ein
angeblicher beschuss von der
ukrainischen seite der solche passieren
der würde passieren und dann würde
russland reagieren also diese
gemengelage die gibt es das gibt also
international diese befürchtungen wie
hoch sehen sie denn die gefahr dass
vielleicht also auch ein beschuss von
sage ich jetzt mal
ein beschluss erfunden wird also so muss
man es ja vielleicht eigentlich sagen
der dann so gar nicht stattgefunden hat
natürlich gibt es ein risiko das ist das
ist fakt wir wir selber journalisten
haben kaum chancen in der ost ukraine
also gerade in den separatisten gebieten
und zu recherchieren wir haben keine
chance das zu überprüfen was dort
verbreitet wird
ja die die chance und die möglichkeit
besteht wir haben auf alle fälle das
gefühl das von russischer seite aus die
situation eskaliert wird
das in den pro-russischen
rebellengebieten separatisten gebieten
während werden jetzt die männer im alter
von 18 bis 55 jahren eingezogen es gibt
eine general mobile machen und die
dürfen auch die orte nicht verlassen ja
und ich kenne selber personen dort die
heute antreten mussten und ich bin
gespannt was dann passiert also was
werden sie dann tun wenn die gesamte
männliche bevölkerung
ja mobil gemacht wurden und wie steht es
um die sorgen um die angst innerhalb der
bevölkerung also auf der ukrainischen
seite wo sie ja auch sind bleiben die
menschen verlassen die die region um die
grenze oder wie ja wie fühlt sich das an
wie sieht das aus
also wir konnten jetzt in den letzten
tagen keine größeren fluchtbewegungen
beobachten wir haben viel resignation
erlebt gerade hier in mario pohl wenn
sie die leute fragen ja jetzt gibt es ja
die idee dass sich biden und putin noch
mal zusammensetzen vielleicht lässt sich
ja doch eine lösung irgendwie finden die
leute haben keine erwartungen mehr weder
an die politik sie glauben nicht sie
glauben auch nicht das was die medien
verbreiten also haben ganz wenige
menschen gerade heute erlebt die gesagt
haben ja warum nicht man kann es ja noch
mal probieren ja aber der frust ist sehr
groß
auf den in den ländlichen gebieten
gerade was den krieg engagierte ich
hatte ja schon gesagt die leute spüren
es sehr deutlich die machen sich
teilweise sorgen weil verwandtschaft auf
der anderen seite der konfliktlinie lebt
da ist der krieg auch stärker spüren als
hier in der großstadt
wo wir in der nacht ruhig schlafen
können wir hören da von hier nichts
aber in den in den kleinen städten
müsste schon alles näher dran und der
wunsch nach frieden weitaus stärker
ausgeprägt vielen dank für ihre
eindrücke heute abend ginzel und die
ganze lange reportage von ihnen gibt es
dann morgen zu sehen im zdf bei frontal
und über weitere aktuelle entwicklungen
heute vom tag und von dieser ganzen
situation können wir jetzt mit meinem
kollegen sebastian ihm sprechen erst in
level
der ukraine beobachtet von dort die
ereignisse in russland und der ukraine
hatte sebastian
sebastian wegen der lage der
angespannten lage in der ost ukraine gab
es heute moskau eine sitzung des
sicherheitsrats es soll tote auf beiden
seiten gegeben haben in den letzten
tagen und jetzt heute auch die meldung
also russland beschuldigt die ukraine
einen russischen grenzposten beschossen
und zerstört zu haben die ukrainische
armee sagt sie hätten nicht auf diesen
posten gefeuert also immer wieder dieses
eine hin und her dieses eine gegen das
andere wieso ist das so schwer dass sie
unabhängig zu verifizieren
naja auf der einen seite gibt es eben
einfach keine leute die das unabhängig
beurteilen können wir haben das gerade
schon von arndt ginzel gehört osze
beobachter kommen schwer an die gefechte
an journalisten sind kaum vor ort die
das wirklich unabhängig beurteilen
können und dann muss man eben gucken was
vermeldet die eine und die andere seite
und ja dass die haben natürlich eigene
interessen und dann weiß man nicht so
recht was stimmt und was nicht die
russische armee hat heute auch noch mal
vermeldet dass fünf ukrainische
saboteure in russisches staatsgebiet
eingedrungen sein und die saboteure sage
ich jetzt mal anführungsstrichen wurden
getötet das ukrainische militär hat das
aber sofort dementiert also wir wissen
nicht was mit diesen sogenannten
saboteuren passiert ist wir wissen nicht
ob das wirklich stattgefunden hat oder
ob das reine propaganda war wir können
es nicht sagen
und es gibt ja also auch teilweise sogar
ja vielleicht sogar falsche
informationen die also verbreitet werden
also desinformation kann man das dann
auch wirklich schon als einen
desinformations krieg bezeichnen oder
würdest du sagen so weit so weit ist es
nicht
hier hatten die experten mit denen ich
in den letzten tagen in kiew vor allem
gesprochen habe aber auch in deutschland
die sagen das ist schon seit langem ein
informationskrieg aber das ist schon
lange auch teil vor allem der russischen
seite die experten sprechen von einer
hybriden kriegsführung hybride
kriegsführung das bedeutet dass man
militärische aktionen macht aber auch
cyber attacken und dazu gehört dann auch
nochmal propaganda das findet vor allem
auf dem sozialen medien statt telegramm
twitter und so weiter und so fort ich
habe vor zwei oder drei tagen einen
twitter-account gesehen der scheinbar
von den ukrainischen streitkräften war
der wurde erst im februar 2022 erstellt
und der beiträge veröffentlicht die
zeigen dass es explosionen gibt auf
ukrainischem boden dass die russen
angreifen und so was haben wir die
experten gesagt soll panik erzeugen
panik chaos in der ukraine und das ganze
also hybride kriegsführung cyber
angriffe auf banken das soll eben dazu
führen dass die bevölkerung möge gemacht
wird
und was kann man vielleicht auch zu aber
der truppenstärke sagen weil das ist ja
vielleicht auch interessant also wenn
man ganz faktisch drauf schaut wie viele
truppen stehen da noch an der grenze
rund um die ukraine also aufgestellt von
den von den russen von russland und wie
viele wie groß ist die truppenstärke auf
ukrainischer seite
also auch das lässt sich nur relativ
schwer belegen was da wirklich stimmt
und was nicht die nato spricht ja von
150.000 truppen menschen oder soldaten
die um die ukraine zusammengezogen
worden sind ob das stimmt wissen wir
nicht genau und das ukrainische
verteidigungsministerium spricht
ihrerseits von
59.000 soldaten die an den grenzen
zusammengezogen sind allerdings hat die
ukrainische armee circa 200 210.000
soldaten in
also insgesamt unter waffen und könnten
auch noch reservisten einziehen aber
auch da wissen wir natürlich jetzt nicht
genau was stimmt und was nicht das alles
sind informationen von seiten die auch
alle ihre eigenen interessen haben jetzt
haben wir dazu zwei fragen aus der
community ist also die frage ob du das
dann überhaupt so konkret beantworten
worden kannst also elke schlaf bei
youtube youtube fragt sich von wem wird
denn die waffenruhe durchbrochen und
thomas kleine kampmann bei facebook
fragt sich was machen die ukrainischen
soldaten dort
hast du mich gehört sebastian
du hast mich nicht verstanden ich
versuche es noch mal
ich versuche noch mal eine zweite frage
ist jetzt hörst du mich wunderbar wir
versuchen es noch mal ich habe mich
gefragt ob du dann diese fragen aus
unserer community überhaupt so deutlich
beantworten kannst und zwar möchte zum
einen elke schlaf wissen bei youtube von
wem der die waffenruhe durchbrochen und
thomas kleine kommt man bei facebook
fragt sich was machen ukrainische
soldaten dort dort auf wen schießen sie
dort
naja also von wem wird die waffenruhe
gebrochen ich glaube die waffenruhe ist
ja seitdem also dass münster abkommen
2014 2015 das hat eine waffenruhe
beinhaltet und diese waffenruhe wird ja
schon seit jahren gebrochen
vermutlich von beiden seiten also es
wird von beiden seiten geschossen das
heißt die waffenruhe wird auch nicht
eingehalten wer da wie oft die
waffenruhe bricht das lässt sich
natürlich nicht sagen dass sie täglich
gebrochen wird und dass die kämpfe in
den letzten tagen härter geworden sind
heftiger geworden sind das haben
unabhängige beobachter der osze soweit
sie denn das überhaupt können
tatsächlich bestätigt also ich glaube
man kann schon sagen dass die waffenruhe
von beiden seiten gebrochen wird das
lässt sich sagen und was war die zweite
frage die zweite frage ist jetzt auch
schon wieder weg gerutscht aber ich
meine das war bei facebook und die frage
war was das ukrainische militär genau
tut schießen die und wenn ja auf wen
kann man dazu überhaupt gesichert
informationen geben
dazu kann ich keine gesicherten
informationen gehen weil ich nicht an
der kontakt linie bin angeles kinzel hat
das ja vorher erzählt dass von beiden
seiten geschossen wird ich glaube davon
ist auszugehen aber gesichert gar nicht
das nicht beantworten
du hast du fünfter abkommen ab das
angesprochen und das war ja eben heute
auch thema im russischen sicherheitsrat
und da sagte putin also er sieht keine
chance mehr für dieses münster abkommen
wir sprechen gleich darüber schauen uns
aber erst dazu einen beitrag von heiko
kunzmann an
14 hatten hier pro-russische
separatisten verwaltungen unter ihre
kontrolle gebracht in dann jetzt und
luhansk rufen sie sogenannte unabhängige
volksrepublik 'nen aus in minsk im
benachbarten bus beginnen kurz darauf
verhandlungen eine waffenruhe wird
vereinbart anfang 2015 musste der
friedensplan überarbeitet werden 2009 10
noch einmal
der plan sieht folgendes vor beide
seiten die ukraine und die separatisten
sollen gefangene austauschen und aus
einer pufferzone schwere artillerie
zurückziehen die regionen der
separatisten erhalten einen sonderstatus
regionale wahlen sind vorgesehen
außerdem verpflichtet sich die ukraine
die separatisten gebiete nicht länger
wirtschaftlich zu blockieren im gegenzug
sich an die separatisten zu der ukraine
wieder die kontrolle über die gesamte
russische ukrainische grenze
zurückzugeben das abkommen ist aber über
weite strecken bisher nicht umgesetzt
worden weil beide seiten die verträge
anders auslegen
sebastian was könnte das dann für folgen
haben wenn putin jetzt also gar keine
chance mehr für das minsker abkommen
abkommen sieht
ja also heute hat sich ja der nationale
sicherheitsrat zu einer sondersitzung
getroffen dieser spielort moskau der es
heute frisch dazu gekommen diesen
nationalen sicherheitsrat haben sich
verteidigungsminister innenminister
außenminister aber eben auch putin und
vertreter des sicherheitsrates des
sicherheitsapparats des camps getroffen
und die haben gesagt dass sie keine
chance wir sehen dass dieses minister
abkommen tatsächlich umgesetzt wird ja
und die folge wäre dann also es wurde
gesagt dass putin gesagt haben soll dass
er die sogenannten teilrepublik ist die
teilrepubliken die selbsternannten
teilrepubliken lohans und dann jetzt
anerkennen will als staat und damit wäre
das jüngste abkommen hinfällig ja und
das würde zur folge haben dass man
keinen richtigen ausweg mehr aus dieser
krise finden könnte denn das winzige
abkommen wurde ja
wurde ja unterschrieben von allen
staaten dafür dass man da irgendwie
zusammen kommt und wenn dass
das eintritt dass putin diese
teilrepubliken anerkennt diese
teilgebiete anerkennt dann wäre dieses
abkommen tot und dann müsste man wieder
bei null anfangen und das ist natürlich
schwer
umzusetzen in der aktuellen situation
was ist angesprochen also diese
entscheidung über diese anerkennung
dieser beiden teilrepubliken das steht
wohl noch heute aus so heißt es so lesen
wir zum schluss aber noch die frage an
dich was würde das bedeuten für jetzt
die menschen auch in der ukraine
befürchten sie dann quasi das jetzt die
entwicklung der gewalt dort an der
grenze an der kontakt linie also noch
viel schneller eskalieren könnte noch
mehr eskalieren könnte
ja das ist die große frage was dann
passiert es geht die spekulationen
reichen von einmarsch der russen auf
breiter front bis auf eskalation im
donbass bis zu die ukraine könnten
selbst die beiden gebiete angreifen
keiner weiß was dann passiert es gibt
stimmen die sagen dass das eine
provokation sein könnte für die
ukrainische seite loszuschlagen denn das
ist immerhin gebiet das sie selbst auch
für sich beanspruchen aber wie das dann
aufgenommen wird in der bevölkerung das
weiß ich nicht ich habe hier mit leuten
gesprochen die einfach auch angst haben
angst vor krieg angst angst vor
eskalation
und es ist so ein bisschen ja sie sind
so ein bisschen kriegsmüde also ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das zumindest hier
im westlichen teil der ukraine dann
eskaliert aber was genau passiert das
wissen wir nicht gut ich will noch heute
eine entscheidung treffen und es machen
gerüchte die runde dass es zu
demonstrationen von russischen
botschaften kommen könnte das werden wir
sehen wir bleiben am ball und gucken was
die nacht und der abend bringt danke
sebastian ihm nach nefz in die ukraine
und eine zusammenfassung für eine
zusammenfassung der ereignisse des tages
und dieses konflikts die können wir uns
jetzt anschauen von axel sturm
bilder die aus ton jetzt stammen sollen
gefechte in der nacht zwischen
separatistischen und ukrainischen
kämpfern angeblich nicht zu verifizieren
verbreitet über telegramm ein eindruck
über die gewalt in der ost ukraine
zumindest entsteht bilder vom morgen ein
zerstörter grenzposten bei roßdorf in
russland angeblich zerstört von
ukrainischen militärs dementi aus kiew
nicht überprüfbar
mehr als 60.000 menschen aus donetsk und
lohans sind inzwischen in russland mit
ungewisser zukunft
zu bleiben wäre gefährlich vor allem
wenn man in der nähe der front lebt
erst haben wir gedacht wir bleiben hier
eine woche jetzt aber heißt es zwei
wochen vielleicht
spielt russland ein zynisches spiel mit
diesen menschen sie scheinen zum
druckmittel geworden zu sein in der
auseinandersetzung mit dem besten
gestern abend gab es grund zur hoffnung
ein treffen zwischen putin und beiden
steht im raum vermittelt von frankreich
noch diese woche vielleicht zur stunde
aber wieder andere signale aus moskau
putin trifft den sicherheitsrat
der hauptgrund für dieses treffen wir
müssen uns abstimmen und weitere
schritte besprechen wir müssen über den
wunsch der selbsternannten volksrepublik
in lugansk und dann jetzt gesprächen
deren anführer und bitten ihre
unabhängigkeit anzuerkennen noch tag der
sicherheitsrat in moskau sollte russland
die unabhängigkeit der separatisten
gebiete anerkennen wäre das minsker
abkommen so gut wie aufgekündigt und
damit das einzige vertragswerk das
zurzeit einen ausweg aufzeigen kann
noch heute soll putin sich an die nation
richten so lesen wir zumindest bei der
nachrichtenagentur reuters also da ist
noch bewegung drin wir können jetzt aber
noch erstmal weiter über die situation
in der ukraine sprechen mit der
ukrainischen autorin und verlegerin
katharina miesch enco sie ist mir jetzt
aus kiew zugeschaltet hallo frau michiko
hallo frau geschenkt sie sind in kiew
das ist zwar weiter weg vom osten der
ukraine empfinden aber die menschen dort
aktuell in dieser lage die sich wenn ich
weiter entwickelt auch ein ähnliches
level an gefahr an angst an sorge
wahrscheinlich nicht ein ähnliches denn
im osten in dombach
passieren wirklich dramatische sachen
viele menschen müssen ihre häuser
verlassen und das macht glaube ich die
situation für uns in kiew auch viel
dramatischer denn jetzt sehen wir es
eskaliert es gibt schon erste geisel
wirklich wie sie schon gesagt haben in
der sendung menschen werden zum
druckmittel gemacht und
das beunruhigt und wir sehen dass die
situation offen ist der prozess ist ganz
intensiv und wir wissen ja nicht wie es
weitergeht aber
eine schnelle lösung wird es glaube ich
nicht geben und darauf sind wir auch
vorbereitet
warum glauben so weit das möglich ja
wieso glauben sie auch dass es keine
schnelle lösung geben wird glauben sie
verstehe ich das richtig dass es also
eher darauf hinausläuft dass das jetzt
ein dauerzustand ist also die ukraine
unter druck und quasi ja die ukraine in
dieser situation in der sie jetzt gerade
steckt dass das also länger so bleibt
warum glauben sie dass ich glaube dass
weil die truppen ja ganz physisch an der
grenze stehen und das sichert die
unsichere situation
sagt man so und jetzt
eskaliert es in den bars in diesem
sogenannten volksrepublik aber es kann
weiter gehen und die nachrichten die ich
heute gelesen habe dieselbe schüsse und
provokationen von
von der seite der volksrepublik an die
zeigen dass dieses eskalation szenario
schon
realisiert wird und man wartet bloß auf
eine
reaktion von ukrainischer seite die das
erlaubt zu sagen sehen sie die ukraine
provozieren und sie jetzt können wir
zurück richtig zurückschlagen also das
ist auch nicht ausgeschlossen ist auf
verschiedenen ebenen gibt es jetzt druck
auf die ukraine nicht nur auf die
ukraine auch auf den sogenannten westen
auf
unsere partner und
routine wille verhandlung denn er will
alles verhandeln und wird druck machen
das ist klar und wäre das am ende
vielleicht genauso schlimm dieser
dauerdruck zustand nennen wir ihn
vielleicht mal so wäre das am ende
genauso schlimm wie ein tatsächlicher
einmarsch noch mehr kriegerische
handlungen würde dieser druck also die
ukraine auch einfach sehr zu mögen
beides ist schlecht aber ich glaube
solange
ja die
kriegste rektoren nicht
erweitert werden ist es besser
aber wissen sie dieser trug den kennen
wir seit langem der also es gab wirklich
einen
waffenstillstand über monate jetzt vor
dieser eskalation
es gab trotzdem tote eine person oder
zwei am tag
und wir also mit diesem druck leben wir
schon länger und jetzt glaube ich ist in
ukrainische gesellschaft
eine neue angst der angst dass weitere
territorien besetzt oder angegriffen
werden können und die menschen fühlen
sich nicht mehr sicher auch in kiew was
früher nicht der fall war sie sind jetzt
nämlich ja in kiew zwar weiter weg vom
osten der ukraine dafür sehr nah dran an
der grenze zu belarus wo ja auch mehrere
soldaten stationiert sein sollen hat
dass dieses gefühl der unsicherheit noch
weiter befeuert
ja ich versuche natürlich in diesem
hybriden krieg ruhig zu bleiben
keine panik
zuzulassen und natürlich habe ich keinen
wunsch mich zu evakuieren ja oder
wegzufahren
ich glaube es ist jetzt wichtig zu
bleiben
weiter
zu arbeiten
weiterzuleben und
diejenigen zu unterstützen soweit das
möglich ist die mehr ausgesetzt sind
also dieser gefahr und dieser eskalation
das ist jetzt glaube ich eine position
die auch die ukrainische gesellschaft
stärken kann und uns
im inneren ja im land was auch
glaube ich heute ein ziel ist russische
aggression dass die ukrainische
gesellschaft
beängstigt wird banisch wird und wecf
lied oder weniger vertrauen der
regierung
ausspricht also das sind alles ziele und
da müssen wir auch solidarisch bleiben
wenn es um die unterstützung für die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer geht geht es
natürlich auch um die unterstützung von
außen und da gibt es eine frage aus der
community von chris cross chrissi bei
youtube er oder sie möchte wissen wie
schätzen sie die deutsche position und
diplomatie ein machen wir hier zu wenig
um zu unterstützen
[Musik]
ich glaube also ich persönlich
wenn ich ehrlich sprechen darf glaube es
wird so wenig gemacht aber es ist ja ein
offener prozess und wahrscheinlich
braucht die deutsche gesellschaft noch
weitere diskussionen um die situation in
der ukraine
damit sich die parteien auch zu lassen
aktiver zu sein und ihre russland
sentiment noch mal infrage zu stellen
und ja ich glaube jede unterstützung ist
wichtig und für jede unterstützung
müssen wir um sind wir auch dankbar
aber wenn ich die europäische geschichte
und die europäische situation heute
betrachten glaube ich dass deutschland
natürlich eine stärkere position
vertreten könnte und zum frieden in
europa mehr beitragen könnten was meinen
sie genau mit einer stärkeren position
ich glaube es war gut
die solidarität mit der ukraine
durch wichtige symbolische gesten zu
zeigen wenn es nicht um die
waffenlieferung geht dann muss es etwas
anderes sein es muss auf jeden fall
jetzt nicht so diskutiert werden das
nord stream zum beispiel so wichtig ist
es ist vielleicht wichtig ich weiß dass
viele deutsche
geschäftsleute und politiker
dieses projekt in schutz nehmen aber ich
glaube jetzt ist auch nicht die zeit
darüber zu diskutieren und das so zu
beschützen und
ich bin mir sicher dass die diplomaten
und politiker viele möglichkeiten im
auge haben wie sie die situation
beeinflussen können auch durch
sanktionen zum beispiel es gibt ja auch
von unseren anti korruptions endlos
jetzt listen und infografiken mit den
menschen die ihre gelder in deutschland
haben oder ihre aktive also es gibt
schon druckmittel und das muss man sich
überlegen
ich möchte gerne noch ein paar stimmen
aus unserer community aufgreifen und
zwar schreibt jemand müller bei youtube
die menschen in der ukraine haben sich
für die freiheit entschieden und der
westen muss alles dafür tun dieses land
in seinem freiheitskampf zu unterstützen
putin hat angst vor der demokratie
gleichzeitig gibt es aber auch von
hans-werner karpfenteich bei youtube die
meinung es gibt wie in jedem konflikt
keine guten die nato stellt ihre waffen
auf der einen seite auf russland auf der
anderen und dann sind die blöden immer
die anderen gleichzeitig von mutter
übrigens auch noch eine frage die ich
gerne an sie stellen möchte und zwar
schreibt er gibt es denn viele menschen
in den grenzgebieten die tatsächlich
eher teil russlands sein wollen wie
viele deren stimme sollte man zumindest
nicht ignorieren was
sagen sie dazu es ist also zu dieser
letzten frage erst mal ich glaube
wirklich es gibt solche menschen ich
habe das dann auch reportagen gelesen
über die situation dort über diejenigen
die jetzt weg gefahren oder weg gebracht
wurden man nennt das evakuierung ja in
russischen medien
oder
so offiziell und es gibt auch menschen
die geblieben sind und
sie haben verschiedene vorstellungen wie
eigentlich viele menschen hier da hat
eine eigene position was sie glaube ich
verbindet ist die unsicherheit diese
gerne loswerden möchte und alle sind
müde von diesem krieg und ich glaube die
menschen denken sie jetzt in der logik
wir müssen wir wollen uns einem land
anschließen das uns frieden bringt sei
dass russland oder die ukraine
also wichtig ist glaube ich die menschen
dort zu unterstützen
und zu reiten auch und dann wenn sie
wieder in einer demokratischen situation
leben dann können sie sich entscheiden
dann können sie eine entscheidung
treffen
aber diese volksrepublik
das wäre vielleicht gut über sie mehr zu
erzählen es ist es sind keine
demokratischen
phänomene und da werden menschen
verfolgt gefoltert und erleben sie auch
nicht gut also wirklich schlimmer als in
russland glaube ich und natürlich auch
schlimmer als in der ukraine
deshalb weiß ich nicht ob wir in dieser
situation wirklich über selbstbestimmung
sprechen müssen können ich glaube die
selbstbestimmung wurde diesen menschen
genommen und das ist ein problem
und zur frage demokratie ukraine und
europa bin ich der meinung
das nicht nur die ukraine geschützt
werden muss sondern die möglichkeit der
demokratie und einer demokratischen wahl
und das steht jetzt
gesagt man das auf dem spiel
nicht nur die ukrainische
situation oder nicht der wohlstand der
ukraine sondern wirklich eine sichere
ordnung in europa und auch eine
vorstellung davon wie die welt
organisiert wird wie europa weiter
leben kann und das ist wirklich nicht
pathetisch das ist politisch und
strategisch sohn
sie sagten die menschen sind müde jetzt
schon müde auch was macht dieser
dauerhafte alarm zustand und dieses
zermürben mit den menschen in ihrem land
ja das nimmt einfach die zukunft glaube
ich es ist schwer etwas aufzubauen
und es ist sowieso nicht sehr einfach in
der ukraine aber
unter dieser permanenten gefahr ist es
schwer zu verstehen wie wo es weiter
führt und ob es überhaupt sinn macht
jetzt die pläne für das nächste oder
über das übernächste jahr zu bauen und
das möchte ich gerne
anders haben für mich auch persönlich
und für
andere ukrainer und ukrainerinnen
zum schluss dann vielleicht noch sehen
sie irgendeine lösung sehen sie im
moment irgend einen ausweg
man sehen ich glaube es ist nicht so
einfach und es ist wirklich
situationsbedingt gestern gab es nimmt
er denkt tag um die gefallenen in der
revolution in meydan und ich war auch
kurz dort und habe mich ein bisschen
erinnert an die ereignisse und jetzt bin
ich
irgendwie
in einem ähnlichen zustand also
ich habe das gefühl wir sind jetzt
drehen in einem sehr intensiven prozess
jeden tag gibt es etwas neues
mal der zug von russland dann der zug
von der ukraine dann von den usa dann
von anderen europäischen ländern dann
gibt es irgendwelche verhandlungen dann
gibt es irgendwelche eskalationen und
ich bin sicher dass in einer woche diese
ganze landschaft schon anders aussehen
wird deshalb wird glaub ich ist ist es
jetzt wichtig in jedem augenblick zu
überlegen was den frieden bringen kann
und so kommen wir auch endlich zu einer
lösung
sagt katharina micenko autorin und
verlegerin aus kiew in der ukraine
vielen dank für das gespräch
danke
und auch euch vielen dank natürlich für
eure aufmerksamkeit fragen und
kommentare wir haben das thema für euch
weiter im blick und gehen dann jederzeit
wieder live bis dahin tschüss